une ville non un village 528 habitants
[Musique]
528 et demi au tout le monde est prêt là
bas de la sympathie partout beaucoup de
chaleur humaine
[Musique]
ah je ne vous ai pas présenté village
verfeil sur seye dans le tarn et garonne
vous savez vous connaissez la
température et ben voilà des copains et
il est plus question de se faire sonner
les cloches
mais de faire tinter les carillon des
magasins
oui tu es bien rasé c'est à la bonne
franquette
ceux là vont travailler de nuit pendant
que nous autres nous allons faire une
veillée comme dans le bon vieux temps
nous faisons les présentations monsieur
qu'est ce que vous êtes vallée et vous
monsieur maires du pays et monsieur
agriculteurs et monsieur en manche et
instituteurs banos elle est aussi un
mariage écoles le jeune agriculteur
monsieur et madame monsieur et vous
maría kaká yérim chirurgie en cover
iphone
n'oublier personne à son sérieux si
costaud j'aimerais et cette petite dame
là que fait-elle jeu de chasse n y pense
et la grille et je les revends votre
jeunesse et puis je les remets dallas à
gages et ben l'audi a8 en mangerait
aujourd'hui et puis je les soupes ou
pour faire tomber la peau
[ __ ]
gfh et voilà monsieur qu'est ce que vous
faites à générer du maïs ans et reposant
sera rapide
moi je chantais et votre calendrier vous
la voyez gervais madame qu'est ce que
votre chat mais quand même c'est parfois
nous fait des mimiques et bouna keita
vous savez faire unique
non monsieur je suis lorraine mais
j'apprends pour fermer les mines sont
faites avec de la farine de blé et de la
farine de maïs que l'on compare à celle
que l'on m'a jamais déçu
oui cette histoire du vin chaud me
rappelle l'histoire et qui arrivera dans
des vaisseaux un ancien de la maison
j'en ai la répartie très proches et se
trouve en invité la jeune garde pas où
chacun se brûler en essayant par
l'ennemi celle qui était bouillant ce
problème à me dégager le livre à un
petit accident
il laissa échapper un soupir tout le
monde ouvrier en deux par un avis les
trophées vous savez la situation ils se
mettent à haïr vient de sortir du landy
de ceux des fruits attendus dit enroulé
était jeune oui est ce que vous allez
continuer plus tard les veillées à
l'ancienne est déçu mais c'est sur la
finition superpole la tradition de ce
père par ce merveilleux dans la bouche
après une veillée comme ça avoue le
courrier leur premier doublé la part des
fidèles au poste
[Musique]